[Music]
time now for final exam we determine
which of our Fox News regulars has been
paying attention to the news you'd
assume all of them we're about to find
out this week's defending champion is
Fox News correspondent Grip Jenkins he's
won a number of times in a row his
latest challenge our friend Town Hall
editor Katie Pavlich now as you know
Katie your competitor has won four times
in a row each time he's been wearing a
sling for his injured arm which he
destroyed on Fox and Friends weekend oh
now he's out of this sling which makes
him even faster so good I need both arms
to be Katie she's gonna absolutely
really good this is what he does I think
this is him so hands on buzzers I ask
the questions the first person to buzz
in gets to answer the question you have
to wait until I've completed the
question before buzzing in each correct
answer gets you one point each incorrect
answered subtracts a point from their
total best of five wins okay are you
ready ready outstanding question one the
president of States just told reporters
he is considering a pardon not only for
former Illinois governor Rod Blagojevich
but also for which domestic goddess
Katie Pavlich Stewart Martha Stewart is
it Martha Stewart a pardon now for
Martha Stewart Stewart you'll remember
was convicted back in 2004 of
obstructing justice in line to the
government about why she unloaded stock
just before the price plummeted the
president says she quote used to be one
of my biggest fans Martha Stewart not
only a genius at place and convicted
he's in the lead there's a multiple
choice question France the country just
discovered its own version of spider-man
a man from Mali the country of Mali
scaled the front of an apartment
building to save a toddler from falling
off the balcony that man has now been
offered a new job as a reward for his
heroism is that job a a high-rise window
washer be firemen or see a circus
acrobat Griff Jenkins fireman fireman
we're as we say in our country
firefighter
is it firemen a 22 year old being called
a real life spider-man bravely using his
own momentum to swing from one balcony
to another reaching the child in less
than 30 seconds he has also been given a
job as a fireman
good for him outstanding that was kind
of compelling one two one
question three in Brock Worth England
this week citizens competed in an
unusual competitive tradition
participants hurled themselves down a
steep hill it was a race to catch a
rolling piece of what type of food Grif
Jenkins cheese cheese cheese to the tape
we go these people rolling chase cheese
the cheese is rolling down at about 70
miles an hour there's the winner and he
didn't even win any money you just want
the cheese to be a Fox News report
you're up on the cheese stories we're
told there was no foreign policy on the
exam whatever okay so it's Jenna one
question for in the age of email the
United States Postal Service's trying
something new in order to attract
business this summer the Postal Service
will introduce a scratch-and-sniff what
postal service crash stamp stamp
what else could it be I don't know let's
roll the tape
as you can see delicious ice pops
they'll smell sweet and delicious
like summer smell it before it goes in
the mail with all the other mail that
that clip was from GMA so I just want to
say that Fox News can confirm it is
indeed a scratch-and-sniff stamp damn
right alright so now Grif Jenkins always
finds himself in this place he brings it
right to the end here's the final
question which Tennessee United States
Senator was just booed by a hometown
crowd when the president called out his
name at a rally in Nashville Kitty
Pavlik senator bob Corker senator
retiring corker well know me to say
before we roll the tape this will decide
the outcome of tonight's final exam roll
the tape please
senator bob Corker
I cannot believe that you d throned
Griffin graduation no no me I took the
sling off I was ready I knew I was
against it here's competitor
congratulation last thing it's one of
those paradoxes it's almost like out of
the beatitudes it's like now that you're
not disabled you're weaker yes
apparently so and you know I should
point out too for a boy from Tennessee
beat from a gorgeous woman from Arizona
it's just you know poetic justice li and
congratulation thank you so much you win
our Eric wimple terrifying say your mug
I don't know there's there's this
picture you can drink your coffee pouch
thank you it was great to see you back
for the round of Champions okay
join us next week when we determine
which Fox News regulars are paying
attention to the job they're paid to do